wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass Vladimir
Putin einen Doppelgänger hat schaut mal
das sind Aufnahmen von Putin wie er die
von Russland Überfallene Stadt Ron in
der Ukraine besucht und hier Putin auf
einem Spielplatz im ukrainischen
mariopol beide Besuche haben nah an der
Front stattgefunden das ist erstmal
nicht so verwunderlich aber nach beiden
Besuchen gab es die Gerüchte Putin wäre
gar nicht da gewesen sondern ein
Doppelgänger auf der Plattform Ex haben
wir z.B diesen Post gefunden in dem drei
Fotos von Putin verglichen werden auf
allen dreien scheint sein Kinn irgendwie
unterschiedlich auszusehen und über
putin wird generell viel spekuliert mal
schreiben die Medien er sei schwer krank
und dann dass er sich einfach aus Angst
verstecken würde in manchen Medien und
in Teilen der russischen Bevölkerung
wird er deshalb manchmal auch Opa im
Bunker genannt deshalb gibt es nach
öffentlichen Auftritten immer wieder
Gerüchte dass es gar nicht der echte
putin war teilweise ist die Rede von
mehr als drei Doppelgängern die ihre
Ähnlichkeit zu Putin wohl auch durch
chirurgische Eingriffe optimiert haben
na ja und nicht nur auf Social Media
wird spekuliert sondern auch von
hochrangigen Militärs der Ukraine und
von Politikwissenschaftlern aus Russland
aber woher kommen die ganzen Gerüchte um
den doppelten Putin was ist dran an der
Geschichte gibt es den russischen
Staatschef wirklich mehrfach das erfahrt
ihr in der neuen ZDF heute
backgroundcheck folge ich bin der
Doppelgänger von Jan Schippmann moin und
bevor es losgeht lasst doch gerne ein
Abo auf dem Kanal
[Musik]
als erstes haben wir uns mal ein paar
von Putins Auftritten aus der letzten
Zeit angeschaut vor allem die bei denen
es immer wieder Zweifel gab ob das nicht
doch eher ein Doppelgänger sein könnte
März 203 Wladimir Putin sitzt am Steuer
eines Autos und fährt durch die besetzte
Hafenstadt Mariupol in der Ukraine neben
ihm der russische
vizeministerpräsident auf einem
Spielplatz sprechen die beiden Männer
über den Wiederaufbau der Stadt Putin
trifft Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner und
besucht sie sogar in ihren Wohnungen man
könnte jetzt sagen na ja der Mann führt
einen Krieg es ist klar dass er Bilder
erzeugen will die ihm nutzen aber so
einfach ist es nicht denn zum einen gab
es dafür natürlich große Kritik aus der
Ukraine ein Berater von Präsident
zelenski hat den Besuch als zynisch
bezeichnet Putin als Mörder von
tausenden Familien hätte hier nur sein
Werk der Zerstörung bewundern wollen
mariopol ist nämlich seit den ersten
Kriegswochen ein Ort von brutalen russ
Angriffen und großer Zerstörung umso
mehr provoziert Putins Besuch die
ukrainische Seite zum anderen ist da die
russische Seite putin wird dort nämlich
manchmal als Opa im Bunker bezeichnet
weil er sich aus Sicherheitsgründen so
selten in der Öffentlichkeit zeigen soll
und jetzt soll er auf einmal direkt an
der Front gewesen sein Zweifel an diesem
Auftritt gibt's auch auf Ex unter
anderem von stevenh Hall er ist Doktor
für russische Politik an der University
of Bath Hall stellt in dem Post nicht
nur die doppelgängerthese in den Raum er
hält auch die Treffen mit den Anwohnern
für gefaked das seien eher
Sicherheitsleute von Putin als wirkliche
Bewohner von Mario Pool dafür spricht
auch noch etwas anderes im Hintergrund
der vom Krimmel veröffentlichten
Aufnahme gibt es einen leisen
Zwischenruf einer
Frau sie ruft das ist alles nur Show der
krmmel scheint sein Video im Nachhinein
allerdings geupdatet zu haben an der
Stelle wo es nur unsichere Blicke der
Leute um Putin gibt ist jetzt ein ganz
leiser Piepton zu
hören aber Moment war das überhaupt
Putin auch ein Berater des ukrainischen
Innenministeriums hat Zweifel putin war
möglicherweise gar nicht selbst in
mariool sondern ein Doppelgänger und das
erkenne man am Kinn ein paar Wochen
später am 18 April 2023 veröffentlich
der Kremmel dann diese Bilder Wladimir
Putin besucht die russischen Truppen an
der ostukrainischen Front in luchansk
sitzt er mit hochrangigen Militärs an
einem Tisch und wünscht dem
Servicepersonal vor Ort ein frohes
Osterfest und auch hier gab es nach der
Veröffentlichung viele offene Fragen
unter anderem über den Zeitpunkt der
Kremmel hatte zwischenzeitlich behauptet
die Fotos sein am 17 April entstanden
allerdings hat Putin in der
Videoaufnahme davon gesprochen dass
Ostern bald ansteht das orthodoxe
Osterfest war am 16 April also schon vor
der angeblichen Aufnahme heißt zumindest
der Zeitpunkt kann schon mal nicht ganz
gestimmt haben die Aufzeichnung vom
Krimmel wurde auch hier im Anschluss
noch bearbeitet und die Wörter
rausgeschnitten und es geht noch weiter
bei der gleichen Reise soll Putin auch
seine Truppen in Cherson besucht haben
hier steigt aus einem Helikopter aus und
begrüßt seine Leute vor Ort Alexi
Danilov der Sekretär des nationalen
Sicherheits und verteidigungsrates der
Ukraine hat sich zu den besuchen dann im
Fernsehen geäußert und da behauptet
son und luans sei niemals der echte
Putin gewesen der sei nämlich ein sehr
verängstigter Mann der sich niemals so
an die Front trauen wirde seiner Meinung
nach sei das ein gewöhnliches Dubel
gewesen davon gebe es mehrere jetzt ist
die Frage die ich mir hier Stelle ist
diese ganze Doppelgänger Geschichte nur
Propaganda oder gibt es Putin wirklich
mehrmals na ja um der Sache näher zu
kommen haben wir mal in die
Geschichtsbücher geschaut und was soll
ich sagen Putin wäre definitiv nicht der
erste Diktator mit Doppel Gänger kennt
ihr ihn hier oder eher die beiden auf
den Bildern sieht man nämlich den
ehemaligen sowjetischen Diktator Josef
Stalin bzw Stalin und sein Dubel davon
soll Stalin gleich mehrere gehabt haben
der Grund er hatte einfach zu viele
politische Feinde um öffentlich
aufzutreten deshalb soll sein damaliger
Sicherheitschef die doppelgängeridee
gehabt haben das stalinubel links hat
sich erst Jahrzehnte später geautet sein
Name Felix dadajev er wurde während des
Zweiten Welt Kriegs an der Front schwer
verletzt und erst für Tod erklärt obwohl
im Krankenhaus dann festgestellt wurde
dass er noch lebt ließ man es beim
Totenschein denn der junge Mann sollte
ein anderer werden 2008 machte dadav
seine Geschichte öffentlich wie er aus
dem Nichts nach Moskau geflogen wurde
und ihm dann dort beim Essen erklärt
wurde für wen er in Zukunft den
Doppelgänger spielen soll für Josef
viserionovit daschwili besser bekannt
als Josef Stalin D daev musste den
Diktator komplett studieren ihm wurden
Aufnahmen gezeigt um Stalins Gesten
seine Mimik sein Gang und seine Stimme
so gut es geht zu imitieren nicht alle
glaubten D dievs Geschichte ein
führender russischer Historiker
bezeichnete das ganze als völligen
Unsinn da diev war nämlich 40 Jahre
jünger als der sowjetische Diktator und
er war damals ein bekannter Schauspieler
und ehemaliger Ausbilder beim
Geheimdienst wie konnte so jemand also
unentdeckt bleiben der da erzählte im
Interview selbst dass er 11 Kil zunehmen
musste und Ex em aufwendig geschminkt
wurde außerdem habe er so viel
durchgemacht dass er sowieso viel älter
ausgesehen habe auch wenn es Zweifler
gab 196 hat das russische
Verteidigungsministerium die Geschichte
offiziell bestätigt außerdem durfte
dadev seine Story mit Erlaubnis von
Vladimir Putin in seiner Biografie
erzählt aber stalin war nicht der
einzige auch ein anderer bekannter
Diktator soll Doppelgänger gehabt haben
Saddam Hussein der ehemalige Staatschef
des Irak 2002 gingen diese Bilder um die
Welt Saddam Hussein sitzt zusammen mit
Jörg Heider einem Rechtspopulisten aus
Österreich der 2008 verstorben ist
Heider soll laut Dokumenten des
irakischen Innenministeriums 5 Millionen
Dollar von Saddam Hussein bekommen haben
und zwar für die geleisteten Dienste ob
damit nur das Foto gemeint ist oder noch
mehr lässt sich nicht rausfinden ganz
offiziell bestätigt wurde das Ganze
nämlich nicht genauso wenig wie Husseins
Doppelgänger auch bei dem Treffen gab es
Gerüchte dass Heider hier nicht in
echten H hin sondern nur ein dubbel
getroffen hätte Hussein soll mindestens
drei Doppelgänger gehabt haben in
Recherchen des auslandsjournals haben
sich 2002 zumindest einige Hinweise
darauf ergeben unter anderem will ein
HNO-Arzt unterschiedliche Körpermerkmale
bei Fernsehauftritten von Hussein
festgestellt haben außerdem soll ein
Rechtsmediziner 450 Fotos von Hussein
verglichen und damit Doppelgänger
enttharnt haben wie valide diese Angaben
sind ist schwer zu sagen bei Hussein
kann man also im Gegensatz zu Stalin
nicht klar sagen ob er dubels hatte oder
nicht hier scheiden sich die Geister ein
ehemaliges CIA Mitglied hat die
Behauptungen im Interview z.B klar
verneint das Ding ist dass Stalins
Doppelgänger bekannt geworden ist ist
eine absolute Seltenheit auf
Regierungsseiten oder in
Geheimdienstkreisen wird alles dran
gesetzt Doppelgänger zu vertuschen und
deren Identität nicht preiszugeben unter
anderem aus Sicherheitsgründen aber wie
sieht's denn jetzt mit Putin aus wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass er wirklich
hier in marioopol durch die Stadt
gefahren ist oder in luchansk seine
Truppen besucht hat gibt es Putin
vielleicht wirklich doppelt und dreifach
putin ist ist eine Figur ja die
geschaffen worden ist die bestimmtes
Image hat
und um die es sozusagen Gerüchte gibt
was Krankheit betrifft
was
möglicherweise er sei gestorben und es
gibt ein Doppelgänger für ihn das ist
Stefan Meister er ist
Politikwissenschaftler und beschäftigt
sich schon seit Jahren mit der
russischen innen und Außenpolitik in
Russland gibt's ja keine öffentliche
Debatte die unabhängig existiert sonder
es ist ja immer eine eine manipulierte
Debatte eine dete sagen die vom von
staatlichen Institutionen und Medien
sozusagen beeinflusst werden das Absurde
ist dass der Kremmel sich offiziell von
diesen ganzen Gerüchten immer wieder
distanziert da heißt es dann putin ist
lebendig gesund und kann problemlos in
der Öffentlichkeit auftreten er hat kein
Doppelgänger gleichzeitig versucht der
Kremmel laut Meister beim Hintergrund
Gerüchte zu streuen um den Mythos Putin
am Leben zu erhalten also quasi je
weniger man sicher über ihn weiß desto
besser es wird unter anderem spekuliert
dass der russische Historiker Valeri
Solow dem K sehr nahe steht und der
streut seit Jahren Gerüchte über Putins
Gesundheitszustand und Doppelgänger
offiziell gilt soloway in Russland als
ausländischer Spion kann aber ohne
Einschränkung weiter dort leben das
lässt natürlich Zweifel aufkommen ein
Grund für die Gerüchte könnte z.B sein
dass man vor den Wahlen 2024 Aufstände
vermeiden will also nach dem Motto wenn
Putin sowieso krank ist lohnt es sich
auch nicht zu demonstrieren aber das ist
natürlich alles nur Spekulation auch von
ukrainischer Seite werden Gerüchte gest
nur mit einer komplett anderen
Stoßrichtung dericht muss man auch sehr
sehr vorsichtig sein was da aus
ukrainischen Quellen kommt weil dahinter
einfach auch ein bestimmtes Interesse
steht ja vielleicht auch eine gewisse
Verunsicherung in Russland selber zu
streuen uns vielleicht auch zu
beeinflussen mit Blick auf Putin und und
wie ernst wir ihn nehmen oder wie wir
wie wir mit ihm umgehen die Ukraine will
Putin mit solchen Gerüchten natürlich
Schwächen auf dem Schlachtfeld und in
den Köpfen der Menschen zu diesem
konventionellen Krieg gehört auch ein
Informationskrieg dazu der ist extrem
wichtig und die Ukrainer sind sehr sehr
gut darin auch Diskurse vor allem im
Westen zu beeinflussen aber es gibt noch
ein anderes Gerücht das immer wieder
auftaucht und zwar die Behauptung Putin
sei eigentlich ja schon längst tot man
wolle einfach nur das russische System
aufrechtterhalten aber wäre das
überhaupt möglich ob das was ist was
dann länger funktioniert dass man es
vielleicht nicht ankündigt für für ein
zwei Wochen ja aber dann über längeren
Zeitraum sozusagen so ein Zustand zu
erhalten irgend muss er dann
Entscheidungen auch Treffen das Heß es
würden schnell Diskussion darüber
entstehen wer Putins Rolle jetzt
übernimmt also wenn Wladimir Putin
wirklich tot wäre würden wir es
wahrscheinlich merken am Ende muss man
sagen ob Putin wirklich Doppelgänger
einsetzt können wir nicht sicher
beantworten wir haben einfach keine
Beweise für bestimmte Sachen und ganz
viel sind halt Verschwörungstheorien die
an verschiedenen Fronten sozusagen
weitergewoben werden und die eben auch
vom Kremmel beeinflusst werden also das
allermeiste in dieser Debatte ist
einfach Spekulation vor allem eben
Putins Gesundheitszustand und auch der
ein z von Doppelgängern kann einfach
nicht klar belegt oder widerlegt werden
ausschließen kann man es aber nicht ich
kann mir das gut vorstellen dass es
Doppelgänger für von Putin gibt dass man
vielleicht auch ablenkt wenn er
irgendwelche Reisen unternimmt und er da
auftaucht und dann da auftaucht oder
dass er auch vielleicht es tatsächlich
vermeidet in bestimmte Mengen zu gehen
und dafür bestimmten dafür eben auch ein
Doppelgänger oder vielleicht auch
mehrere Doppelgänger hat ziehen wir mal
ein Fazit doppelgängertheorien sind
nichts Neues ob aus gesundheitlichen
oder
Sicherheitsgründen allem in autoritären
politischen Systemen kursieren um die
Machthaber schnell Gerüchte belegen
lassen Sie sich in den seltensten Fällen
weil die Beteiligten das ganze natürlich
geheim halten wollen im Fall von Putin
werden die Gerüchte sogar gezielt aus
der Politik gestreut einerseits von der
Ukraine um Putins Position zu schwächen
und andererseits aber auch vom Kremmel
selbst um den Mythos Putin zu erhalten
beide Seiten nutzen das Motiv also zu
eigenen Propagandazwecken man spricht h
in der Forschung auch von einem
Informationskrieg der neben dem reellen
Krieg stattfindet vor allem social Media
wird genutzt um Informationen aber auch
Desinformation zu streuen und dadurch
eben die Gegenseite zu verunsichern oder
auch Außenstehende Parteien zu
beeinflussen was sagt ihr denn zu der
doppelgängedebatte und für wie wichtig
oder absurd haltet ihr sie und hättet
ihr auch gerne einen Doppelgänger für
was würdet ihr den dann benutzen
schreibt do mal in die
Kommentare falls es noch nicht getan
habt lasst no mal ein Abo da und hier
findet ihr noch ein anderes Video aus
unserem background Check darin haben wir
uns die größten Mythen zu Windkraft
angeschaut